I think solar power is one of the
biggest changes that the world will see
in my lifetime it's a truly
revolutionary technology I've had solar
panels on the roof of my house for seven
years and just recently I've upgraded it
and fitted a tesla powerwall so even if
the battery's completely flat by the
time I'm up and around with the dogs
it's got probably three four five
percent and that's enough interestingly
to boil a kettle put on the toaster on a
sunny day mid morning it's at 50% I know
that I'm capturing most of that
electricity for later use so it's a very
very different mindset
the Tesla I'm embarrassed to admit I
reckon 2025 times a day I'll check it I
get a little bit obsessive with I admit
so basically what a power lets you do is
use the power from the Sun at night when
the family's here and we're cooking that
were laundries during the washing
machines on the tumble dry of the
dishwasher the kettle I know we're not
taking that power from the grid which we
used to be when we only had solar panels
and didn't store the energy now we're
taking all that power from the power
wall the glory is it's guilt-free use
the vast majority of electricity that we
use in this house
is coming from the Sun and that is a
great feeling
[Music]